what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this man's coming at us this man for
whatever reason why especially if you're
just gonna get hurt every year and not
even play
this past weekend a phenomenal podcast
actually I was a massive fan it was I am
yeah I guess was we was Compton I think
his eyesight's real bad he has CT
EFG dude I saw it that's between you
guys man NFL veterans and Barstow Sports
employees Will Compton and Taylor Luan
have publicly called out Theo Von over
comments made at their expense on
back-to-back episodes of Theo's podcast
this past weekend the busting with the
boys boys officially declared this beef
beef a few weeks ago on episode 211 of
their podcast after claiming theoven's
been taking weird and unprovoked shots
at them this man's coming at us
yes this man for whatever reason so for
some context this past weekend a
phenomenal podcast actually I was a
massive fan I am yeah I guess was we was
last two episodes George Kittle and
Kayla Presley he's thrown some throw
some weird shots at the boys weird shots
punch goes right in the groin for no
reason yeah yeah
um it seems like he has beef with me
faking the whole Kayla Presley death
when Caleb was on a ventilator the
comments made by Theo Von that they're
referring to In that clip happened on
episode 435 of this past weekend
featuring George Kittle where Theo made
a joke about Taylor luan's recent string
of injuries and Then followed that up
with a similar joke about both Taylor
and will in the very next episode Sarah
I was talking to Taylor one today he was
like yeah my workout started at 5am I
was like why that's great yeah why
especially if you're just gonna get hurt
every year and not even play
oh well maybe
this is his change maybe he's doing
something different yeah you know Hey
Taylor he'll be healthy man he'll be
fine yeah it is some of it I think is
his attitude gets stuck in his knees him
[__] ruins him I mean yeah like
Compton I think his eyesight's real bad
he has CTE yes ctefg dude I saw that's
between you guys man now although
busting with the boys claimed that
theovan's remarks were unprovoked
Theo says that his reasoning for the
beef stems from being on the receiving
end of a prank where will Compton
convinced him that fellow barcel Sports
employee and Theo's good friend Caleb
Presley had suddenly passed away
people were dying dude and then you said
you guys said you did you know I got
that text on that airplane and that's
when Will Compton said that you died
yeah so we got up and I got out Will
Compton comes and visits me for in the
hospital and I told him what happened my
family's telling what happened because
it was funny afterwards they think it
scared them in the moment he's like
we'll send a video Let's Tell Theo you
died tell Theo you did it and you die so
he texted you and he was like dude did
you hear what happened to Caleb and you
hit him back right away you're like what
happened and he was like he passed away
and then he immediately took a photo of
me doing like this in my little gown but
then you're on a plane so the photo
didn't come in the photo didn't come
yeah and he's like I'm absolutely gutted
that's what he said with the photo I
guess and so that's all I got and then
that Wi-Fi kept cutting in and out like
yeah was I was at a little much and far
absolutely but anything for a nice
little laugh yeah you know what I'm
saying and I knew Theo like Theo and I
don't know each other that well
in the world of Giggles yeah all it's
fair yeah yeah I feel really just upset
which who knows if he really is he gets
on that flight when he could have went
and saw Caleb and the joke just played
out longer because he didn't have Wi-Fi
when I landed I found out that it was a
joke and you were still alive so would
you and will still have beef
I mean I would say I'm not super fond of
somebody that's gonna first of all not
even fake their own at least fake your
own death yeah don't throw me under the
bus under the grave it was a complete
coincidence that theavon just randomly
happened to be losing service on a plane
at the exact same time will Compton sent
him a text and because of that he
thought his dear friend was actually
dead for a few hours which is just a
hilarious chain of events if you're the
pranksters but it's also what makes this
entire thing pretty [__] up from
Theo's point of view yeah man I remember
I was I was literally crying in my seat
but I bucked up and kept it together
yeah and then when I landed I found out
that it was a joke and you were still
alive so as we saw earlier Theo first
responded to the fake death prank with a
couple of jokes about Taylor and Will's
NFL careers followed by a few Jabs about
their physical appearances and
discussing different ways in which him
and Caleb could beat them in a fight
which the boys responded to by bringing
up Theo's Road Rules days taking shots
at his personal appearance and debating
the best course of action against Theo
moving forward you fight him if you saw
him
I don't know if it would be on site but
I think if if somebody arranged
something I would say that do you think
you and I could beat them in a fight do
we have guns
I think maybe one gun is hidden in the
ring somewhere oh first man to the gun
no if it's equal opportunity for the gun
I don't think we win really but if we
have them if we bring guns
the way you're verbalizing this I feel
like you have them in like a headline
right now like and you know what that's
a point too they actually talked about
fighting US with guns yeah if you're
talking about a real fist fight we are
gonna body bag both of them no problem
now but if it's a verbal War horrible
verbal war is going on Caleb and Theo
the boy their brains work it's just on a
different level I don't know if it's a
higher level it might be a way sideways
level yeah it's just a different level
than the way our brains work I don't
think anyone can really disagree with
their predictions on how these
altercations could play out in a
physical fight blessing with the boys
might actually kill Theo and Caleb with
their bare hands but in a verbal Battle
of jokes and quick wit theovan and Kayla
Presley are a Dream Team capable of
inflicting the same amount of damage to
Taylor and will if not more JP what'd
you say about Theo Ice Age yeah Theo
looks like the the nut that the squirrel
is just after the whole time
that's how I view Theo there's our best
verbal abuser right there
I can't wait till he comes on you want
any more of that deal whether it's Kayla
Presley Glennie balls or Dave Portnoy
himself theavon and barcel Sports in
general has always been a great
crossover even this thing that they're
calling beef still seems to be somewhat
lighthearted at its root and both sides
are actually being funny making jokes
and remaining entertaining throughout
which is honestly refreshing to see when
you compare to some other beefs in the
comedy world there's a brand new comedy
show on the CW called the Great American
joke off that was created by the same
people who made Whose Line Is It Anyway
each episode features six different
comedians who take turns telling jokes
and responding to different prompts and
situations the show is hosted by Dolce
Sloan and features a ton of talented
comedians like Alonzo Bowden Joe list
Natasha legaro and Ed gamble to name a
few plus three former joke World guests
Mark Norman Fahim Anwar and Matthew
Broussard
Batman
I'm actually like a bat in the bedroom
as well there's a lot of biting and I
squeak at the end
hey do you want to make out in the alley
where my parents were murdered
Alfred likes to watch
how'd you like to get a virus from a bat
that isn't covered
what about my skin tight rubber suit and
young male gymnast assistant made you
think I was gay
one of the main reasons podcasts and
crowd work Clips have become so popular
as of late is because it's really cool
to see comedians thinking on their feet
written jokes are still great obviously
but there's something even funnier when
someone says something you know wasn't
planned which happens a lot in this show
guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Chris Porter two bears one
cave was Burt and Jim Jeffries kill Tony
this week was with Adam Ray Adam Ray was
also the guest on the Harlan Highway we
might be drunk out at Noelle Miller Roy
Wood Jr was on flagrant the already
garbage boys had a busy week being the
guest on the youngest Papa's hour voice
cast and stopping by Chrissy chaos there
are you garbage boys also had the
episode of the week when they hosted
Uncle Joey Diaz for the first time
forget I'm Cuban but I'm white trash I
tell my wife all the time I don't feel
bad I'm white trash too you're making
Cuban sandwiches a Wonder Bread oh no
not that way trash but I have my I love
all the shits over at Hitchin yeah I
love all that I apologize zombie hey I
apologize I didn't know he was going to
say that none
I am white trash brother this past
weekend with the Yvonne talked with
Rayne Wilson The Joe Rogan Experience
had on Paulie Shore logic did the bad
friend's Shuffle last week going on
tiger belly and whiskey Ginger Sean
Patton was on the Honeydew Sarah Sherman
was on stavy's world Sal vulcano was on
the plots podcast this [__] podcast had
on Josh Wolf and Chris O'Connor and
Tommy Pope were the guests on Matt and
Shane's secret podcast as far as new
stand-up specials that are either out
right now or coming out soon nemesh
Patel lucky Lefty is out right now on
YouTube I would definitely recommend
giving that a watch sometime this week
other than that not too many new
specials besides a crop that came out a
few weeks ago like Star Wars halcus's
crowd work special Christopher Titus
zero side effects and John Mulaney baby
Jay which I think could be an early
front runner for special of the year if
you ask me also I'm not sure how many
people know this but these comedy news
update videos that we post here every
single Tuesday are also available to be
downloaded in audio form wherever you
listen to podcasts so if you want to
stay in the comedy loop on the go maybe
you got like a 10-15 minute drive boom
perfect time to catch up on all your
favorite comedians just search joke
World wherever you listen to podcasts
give it a download and boom you're often
the races having the time of your
absolute life listening to the joke
World comedy news update in your car
you're cruising and you're still
thinking in your head I can't wait to go
watch this video on YouTube so I can
still like and comment and subscribe
even though I'm supporting them in the
audio version as well thank you for
watching
at joke world
and the world with wrld